disruption across the Taiwan Strait is
everybody's business and inevitably the
Chinese government will say well no this
is an entirely domestic matter we don't
mess around in your domestic decision
making um but this an entirely domestic
matter it's nothing to do with you and I
say no no this is not an entirely
domestic matter huge International Trade
volumes go through that body of water
the disruption to the movement of key
bits of the componentry of Modern Life
go through that stretch of War it would
be a
catastrophically bad thing for the
global economy and it would be a
Chinese economy it would collapse the
Chinese economy as we're now seeing the
Chinese economy is not all powerful
their economic D dominance is not
inevitable and conflict across the
Taiwan Strait would I I I think collapse
the Chinese economy and bring a number
of other economies down with it